Tracy Clayton: I had this
moment, and I think I tweeted
it, but I was like, "I can't
believe it took me so long
to realize that you are, like,
what I want to be, you know?"
Jackee Harry: Really?
Tracy: Yes, oh my gosh.
Jackee: Going to make me cry.
I'm like, "Really?
Wow."
Tracy: But really I was
just like, "She's hilarious,
and smart, and outspoken,
and just--"
And also funny.
It makes me so mad
people are like,
"Women aren't funny,
there are no funny women."
I'm just like, "How dare you
when Jackee is in the world,
how dare you?"
Jackee: Well, you know
what they mean, though.
It's a very male-oriented
thing, standup for sure.
There used to be
a lot more women,
Totie Fields, Lucille Ball.
I'm talking about
Phyllis Diller, Joan Rivers.
It was a lot, Imogene Coca.
I know my history, you know.
But I don't know, it's
like they disappeared,
and now they're coming back.
But the thing with women is
it's a female thing, but also,
you know, you have these
things you can't talk about.
You know, you know,
that aren't allowed.
Men can talk about anything, you
know, but women, you have to be
careful because people are
looking at the woman first
and then the comedian.
The man comes on, boom.
So, you got to go
right to funny.
It's almost like you got to
go right to funny, you know?
So yeah, it's like
Ellen DeGeneres,
she goes right to funny.
See what I mean?
Tracy: I see, I see.
Jackee: And so
we--but we're getting better.
But I don't know, it's
just one of those things.
Tracy: Who were some of
your early comedic inspirations?
I feel like you could
probably just name them.
Jackee: Lucille Ball.
I love Lucy for real.
Tracy: Since you say
Lucille Ball, it's like
of course, I can see
the influence now.
Jackee: Uh huh, Mae West
for sure, Joan Rivers.
Joan taught me to write down
everything, every joke,
every ad-lib.
And Rodney Dangerfield is
my last mentor.
Tracy: Really?
Jackee: He'd, "Baby, baby,
baby, write down everything.
Baby, baby, you got to get
your mantra,
got to get your mantra, baby.
You know, no respect, baby.
I got no respect."
You know, you got to have
your--mine of course is...
[giggling]
And when you do people
copying, I know you copying.
And keep repeating it and
repeating it and repeating it.
And then you put it
in there, you know?
You got to hammer it out.
Tracy: I wanted to know
what baby Jackee was like.
Like, did you just, like, come
out of the womb funny
and just, like, amazing?
Jackee: No, shy,
very shy, very quiet.
Singing along to the radio.
My earliest memory's maybe
seven or eight, singing along
to the radio, the actual radio
in the house.
We didn't have--yeah.
And TV baby, oh yeah.
Still am.
Tracy: Yeah?
Jackee: Oh yeah, 24/7.
Tracy: How did
you end up acting?
Like, how did
you--did you grow out of it?
Did you break out of it?
Did you act--
Jackee: I was a member of the
glee club from the age of six,
five, you know, singing.
And all through school, all
the way up, I got to junior high
and I got in the play,
school play.
And the first one was
"Oklahoma,"
I didn't get in
the lead in that.
I was mad.
I didn't get the lead
'cause--and I was crying
'cause I was so good.
They said, "No,
you're not a senior."
So, I did "The King and I," and
I got on stage and I was great.
And I got the applause,
and that's when I came.
But I still was shy,
I couldn't speak out.
But then I went and got
acting lessons with
Dick Anthony Williams at
Henry Street Settlement.
And they taught me, you know,
what you call monologues and
things, and how to get up
in front of people and talk.
It took a year and a half
for me to get up.
But when I broke--
Tracy: You broke.
Jackee: And that's what you
have to do if you're going
to do it.
'Cause even now, you have
some actors who are shy,
but I can speak in
front of anybody.
You know, but don't
ask me to do standup.
You know, I'm strong in
anything, I'm a confident woman,
but standup?
Tracy: That's
a different beast.
That is a different monster.
And I tell people all the time,
like, being funny on Twitter
is one thing.
Standing in front of a crowd
and trying to make them--I don't
understand how anybody does it.
Jackee: But I was a sweet kid
and really nice.
And I still am, you know.
Bookworm.
You know, nerdy, corny.
But I had a nice--you know,
I'm a baby boomer, so I had
a nice growing up period,
not tumultuous.
You know, nothing, I mean,
you know, to speak of.
I was a really sweet kid, yeah.
Tracy: I feel like the '90s--in
the '90s,
TV used to be so black.
You know, like there
were so many black sitcoms.
There was "Living Single," there
was "Martin," there was
"Sister, Sister,"
there was--what do
you think happened?
Like, where did all
the black shows go?
Jackee: You know, we
were in fashion because like
blacksploitation in the '70s,
all those black movies,
which were not great, but
they--we enjoyed them.
Tracy: Were necessary also,
you know?
Jackee: What, "Shaft"
and "The Mack,"
you can go--"Superfly,"
on and on and on.
But we just--we're in
and then we're out.
Black people, we're in, we're
hot, but we always resurface
because the creativity
is so original, you know?
But black and white people,
I'm sorry, we're all the same
because we
influence each other now.
'Cause I sure have learned
something from
my little young man.
Tracy: Oh, do tell.
Jackee: It's give and take
now, and that comes from
the evolution and the evolving
of people.
So, I believe in evolving,
and that's what's happening.
You have to evolve constantly.
To understand racism, to
understand gay rights being,
you know, infringed,
you have to learn it.
It's not--you don't just go,
"Oh, that's wrong,"
'cause you said it.
You understand it,
you can fight it.
Tracy: Right, and you have
to do a lot of listening too.
Jackee: It's like
Colin Kaepernick in the NFL.
I understand that, so
you can fight for it.
But if you don't understand, you
know, you really are confused.
So, we have to keep evolving.
You feel me?
Tracy: I feel you, girl,
I feel you.
So, what is the greatest piece
of advice that you've gotten
about acting?
Jackee: From Debbie Morgan,
you know who that is?
When you leave an audition,
leave it there.
Don't take it with you home,
don't take it back.
It took me 40 years to learn
that because I'd get all,
"Did I get it?
What did I do?"
I'd be in the car, I'm talking
about it would last for months.
You, ooh God.
And then somebody gets that
role, and you watch it, go,
"How'd she get that part?"
Tracy: "I'm better than that."
Jackee: Yes, envy, jealousy.
You know the difference
between jealousy and envy?
Envy is, "Why not me?
Why her and not me?"
Jealousy is, "I hate her."
No, really,
that's the difference.
Tracy: I'm learning so much.
Jackee: So, that's the greatest
piece of advice,
and I have followed,
and it works.
Tracy: But it's a practice
to get that, huh?
Jackee: Just
like forgiveness does.
When you forgive somebody,
you have to practice it,
and it works.
Mm-hmm, but you
have to practice.